the introduction of the dcu's Batman is
the Brave and the Bold the Brave and the
Bold is the story of Batman and his
actual son Damian Wayne this is based on
Grant Morrison's great comic book run
Damien Wayne is my favorite Robin he's a
little assassin who Batman tries to get
in line and so this is the story of the
two of them and the beginning of sort of
the bat family in the DCU what is going
on everybody welcome back to the cosmic
wonder I'm Warren Thompson and today we
have some really big news in terms of
the DC Universe specifically about the
new Batman movie the DC Universe is
resetting under the Helm of James Gunn
and Peter Safran DC Studios has
announced their chapter 1 Gods and
Monsters and James Gunn has confirmed
that the new introduction of the new
Batman is going to come in the movie
which is currently titled the Brave and
the Bold and this of course is taken
directly from the comics and also there
was an animated series back in 2008 that
ran for three seasons called Batman a
brave in The Bold and obviously fans are
very excited for a new Batman to come
into a new DC Universe and just to make
sure everybody is aware of this this is
not Robert Pattinson's Batman from the
Batman they are doing a the Batman 2 but
this is what James Gunn calls DC
elseworlds meaning that they're not
going to be a part of the main DC
connected universe so the Batman Robert
Pattinson's Batman is not going to have
any type of connection to this new
Batman or the new universe in general as
far as we're concerned but today we got
a pretty big update about this film
which comes as a nice surprise as we
haven't really gotten much updates about
any of the films with the exception of
getting a release date for Superman
Legacy but it seems that the Batman the
Brave and the Bold now has its director
it looks like James Gunn has locked down
Andy muschietti and if that name sounds
familiar well that's because Andy
mushieri is directing or has already
directed The Flash movie with Ezra
Miller now this report is coming from
onetake news com and this report really
doesn't come as that big of a surprise
because James Gunn before in the past
has stated that he would love Andy
muschietti for another project he
actually said he wanted him for another
project plus not to mention when Andy
muschietti was promoting The Flash in
Toronto Canada he was asked what he
would do if he had his own Batman film
to direct in which he responded I don't
think I can talk to that yet which was
very surprising at the time and made
people think well since he can't talk
about it maybe he is already attached to
a project and it looks like that was
indeed the case because if you're not
involved with a new Batman project at
all you can definitely say what your
thoughts are and what you would like to
do if you had that opportunity but it
does look like he was already attached
to it so couldn't really say anything so
Andy mussieri is directing the Flash and
the upcoming Batman movie The Brave and
the Bold one take news when reporting
the news said this the rumors are true
fresh off of heaps of early praise for
the flash Andy muschietti has been tap
to direct a brave in the Bold for DC
Studios One tech news has confirmed with
multiple sources plus other insiders
have tweeted about this as well such as
viewer Anon and my time to shine hello
all backing up the same report and this
news comes at kind of a really great
time The Flash movie has already been
shown to some fans and a lot of
journalists and everybody so far has
praised this movie stating that it's
just phenomenal one of the best
superhero movies ever made and maybe one
of the best movies ever made and some of
you might have heard the Tom Cruise
story when it comes to The Flash movie
if you haven't here's a quick recap Tom
Cruise met with Warner Brothers about
something we're not going to really
speculate too much on that but they
talked about The Flash movie he heard
about it and he said that he wanted to
watch it and what do you do if you're
the head of Warner Brothers Well you let
Tom Cruise watch the movie so somebody
brought him over a secure version of the
movie to his house stayed there until he
watched the whole thing picked it back
up and left and what did Tom Cruise
think of it well he thought it was
phenomenal he thought it was so so good
that he even called up the director
Andrew machietti who he had never met
before but he called him up and he gave
him praise for the movie because he
thought it was so good and he said that
this is a kind of movie that the world
needs to see right now and we'll figure
out what that means soon when the movie
comes out but Andy muschetti got the
praise and has been getting the praise
for this film The Flash so it comes as
no surprise that James Gunn was so
impressed with his work on the flash
deck he wants him to direct the Batman
the Brave and the Bold so if The Flash
movie really is as good as everybody has
been saying it is then this is an
absolute win for the Brave and the Bold
and the new Batman coming to the DCU now
what's really interesting about this is
that if they have already gotten the
director for the film that means they're
somewhat far along with the process of
getting the script together finalizing
the story starting to get the cast
together and eventually beginning
pre-production so things are moving for
our new Batman coming to the DCU and
right now we know that James Gunn is
kind of taking some time off after
Guardians of the Galaxy vol 3 and really
focusing on his new job at DC and right
now he's taking time to basically work
on all of the projects that are coming
up he even said recently that he's
taking some time off of kind of
debunking a lot of things that go around
on Instagram and Twitter and Etc so it
does seem like the movie is underway and
what we know so far as far as a release
date is concerned we don't know anything
official for the new Brave and the Bold
movie however we do have a release date
for Superman Legacy Superman Legacy
right now has a current planned release
date for July 11th of 2025 and based off
of part of chapter one of the new DCU
that James Gunn has laid out Superman
Legacy is coming out before the Brave
and the Bold And if the order of movies
and projects that James Gunn announced
for his part of chapter 1 reveal Remains
the Same then that means that there are
three projects coming out between
Superman Legacy and the Brave and the
Bold we have one movie The Authority and
then we have two shows Precinct Earth
and Paradise Lost now the shows
shouldn't really get in the way of movie
releases and Superman Legacy is coming
out in the middle of 2025. so the
authority could come out in the
beginning of 2026 which means we could
be getting the new Batman and the DCU
mid-2026 to the end of 2026. it is very
much looking like a 2026 release date
especially if you also consider that the
Batman 2 with Robert Pattinson's Batman
is releasing on October 3rd of 2025. so
they definitely won't release their new
Batman movie the new Batman in the new
DC Universe at the same time or kind of
very close to Batman 2 because that
would one not only confuse audiences but
two probably affect them at the box
office again they exist in separate
universes they do not connect with each
other at least that's what they've said
so far but the best business decision
would of course be to not release them
that close together so it does look like
like I mentioned that mid to late late
2026 release date to get our new Batman
and the DC Universe which will
reportedly be directed by Andy
muschietti and again if the flash is
really as good as everybody's saying it
is then we have great hopes for the new
Batman but hey let us know your thoughts
about this in the comments down below
also if you were one of the lucky people
who got to see The Flash movie please
let us know your thoughts about that
movie Down Below in the comments as well
we are also doing a giveaway we do one
each month the winner gets to pick
between an Xbox series X A PS5 some
Marvel Legends items or some DC items
you get to pick one and we pick a winner
at the end of each month all you gotta
do is subscribe and leave a comment
below that automatically enters you you
can also follow us on Instagram and
Twitter as well we're also on patreon we
have our website and we do have a
Discord server that I'll link down below
as always thank you all so much for
watching wolf wolf
baby